and we start this morning with cleanup
crews that are scrambling to contain a
massive oil spill in southern
california's surf city video from above
shows an oil slick covering about 13
square miles it's forced beaches to
close and wildlife is in grave danger
the worst of it is in huntington beach
about 40 miles south of los angeles
lilia luciano was there lilia good
morning
good morning to you nate look the mayor
calls this a potential environmental
catastrophe and it's felt everywhere one
of the most striking scenes i saw
yesterday between the crude filled shore
and the boats working on cleanup was a
pair of dolphins swimming by and that's
just one of the many species those crews
and the teams on land are working to
protect
thick pockets of sludge continue to wash
up along some of southern california's
most popular beaches this morning
coating everything from the sand to the
wildlife the smell hits you and there is
just
gunk everywhere at least 126 thousand
gallons of oil began pouring into the
pacific ocean over the weekend from an
underwater pipeline about four and a
half miles off shore sending a sheen of
oil from huntington beach to dana point
harbor we are in the midst of a
potential ecological disaster amplify
energy which owns the pipeline shut the
line down and suctioned out the
remaining oil the company's ceo also
pledged full cooperation with the
cleanup effort we are investigating the
source and potential cause of this
incident officials have deployed more
than 2 thousand feet of protective booms
and skimming equipment to try to slow
the spread of the oil and prevent any
further damage to sensitive marshlands
how vulnerable is this area
environmentally speaking this is one of
the most important stretches of
coastline along orange county and
possibly all of southern california
victor leipzig conservation director of
the sea and sage audubon society says
the disaster comes at a critical time as
several different species of seabirds
migrate to the area for the winter the
spill is only a few hours old and so how
many birds or other wildlife are going
to be impacted what impact it's going to
have on vegetation in the marshes along
the coast is still yet to be seen
we've talked about the environmental
impact but there's also an economic
impact the beach is now closed because
of the hazard and to make space for the
cleanup but the beach might remain
closed for weeks if not months according
to the mayor and there's so many
businesses all along the shore that
depend on beachgoers to survive tony
some upsetting pictures there from
southern california lilia thank you very
much